john gray numbers
against arizona in his career he's been
up and down
in his career against the diamondbacks
but a big blow obviously to the
diamondbacks
and this is in the air to charlie in
right field
a lot of wind out there today
ball's going to be carrying 2-1
is in the air left side
drifting back ryan mcmahon into foul
ground now
he won hands it for the second out he
began his career in the orioles
organization but
found his home with the d-backs and he
sends it in the air to left field
lots of room for rymel tapia the win
brings it back towards the infield as
rymel makes the catch
meryl kelly who made his return from
thoracic outlet surgery friday in san
diego needed 94 pitches to get through
four innings
and this is lined toward right it'll
drop
in front of smith an easy first to third
route
for garrett hampson and the rockies in
business early
trevor has dominated arizona pitching in
his big league career
but in this series he's looking for his
first hit
this is loud and deep and
off the top of the wall good read by
tapia he'll get
to third in a second with a double
is trevor story one nothing colorado
and charlie blackmon who is
getting his game in gear with a chance
to
jump on merrill kelly early 2-1
charlie drives it to right up
up and off the top of the wall it's
gonna score
two runs on a 380
foot single
[Applause]
and john drives one to left and this
could be double territory he'll shut it
down
on a wide turn
jam shot somebody's got to get there
peralta runs it down
and hampton has to hustle back a nice
recovery there by david
two outs trevor story the hitter
and trevor lines one to right center
field nobody's gonna catch this one
coming home is hampton story around
second
flying towards third he'll arrive safely
make it four nothing colorado triple
for trevor
[Applause]
oh two strike three and he offered at it
so a strikeout and that is number 700
of john gray's career fifth on the
all-time rockies
punch-out list there's your list
and he gets the strikeout back-to-back
strikeout for gray
to god
line to van meter out there in short
right one away in the fourth
pop them up sky high it's windy and
sunny there
who's got it perdomo chases it down
right behind the mound
1-2 pitch hamson swings on the ground
just short perdomo's got it and fires to
get him
at first two on the inning one two three
second straight
one two inning and seven nerosa down by
merrill kelly
and he got him on a change-up and that's
a slider
but it was set up by that high fastball
oh with two on kelly
and he went strike three that's
strikeout number four
escobar who walked left at second john
putting up a lot of zeroes
four nothing colorado john gray ain't
allowed a thing
three walks and then he ended up
striking out he'll chop this one
slowly to third bare hand pick up by
mcmahon throw to first
they got him with a good stretch by josh
fuentes
excellent play by ryan mcmahon and josh
fuentes
3-2 he's swinging at that one two outs
and it's been all about the off speed
stuff today for john he does not have
his plus fastball he's averaged 92 and a
half
gray twists and fires and walker puts it
in the air
shallow right field blackman coming out
he's got it
six innings in the books john gray is
not allowed to hit
found dom nunez he has hit a comebacker
to kelly
and line to the second baseman van meter
1-1 high fly ball
deep right center field and this one
is gone three-run jack
tom nunez his third of the year make it
seven nothing colorado all dom nunez
does this year is hit home runs he
absolutely crushed that got the fastball
and sent it away but the story now
john gray a whole lot of nothing so far
for arizona you throwing no hitter or
coors field you immediately become the
front runner for the cy young award
count as two no hitters this one's got a
chance and there it goes
peralta the other way breaks up the
no-no he's got a lead-off double
and he's going to head for third they're
slow to pick it up out there david
hustles in
and he's standing up give up one hit
through
six plus in this ballpark uh you can't
be too upset
haven smith under the glove of hampson
and the diamondbacks are on the board
the rbi for pavon
many of the folks here at coors field
come to their feet to applaud the effort
by john he was 12
the previous year 3
this is a tough play because it was a
short hop handled beautifully by story
one
there was nothing he could do other than
stay stay right there he couldn't drop
step
to make the play he couldn't come get it
so he just had to stay there and use
those sweet hands
to snag this ball and once he did that
it's an easy toss over to first
back in the seventh escobar
gets a fast ball and he did not miss it
yeah
eduardo escobar a two-run homer that's
his first
and hold the phone we're not done yet
[Music]
two out to the ninth as bard strikes out
josh rojas
[Applause]
roll to third fuentes he's got his man
ball game over daniel bard
comes on gets the final two outs for his
second save
of the year john gray took a no-hitter
into the seventh
he gets the win he's one and one